All right, next question is on
rheumatoid arthritis. A few months ago I
started coaching a client with
rheumatoid arthritis or RA. She has
reported that since she started training
she has not experienced any symptoms or
flare-ups. She's getting stronger and
really enjoys training. I was wondering
if you could speak to the benefits of
resistance training for people with RA
and if there are any special
considerations that I need to be aware
of. Uh so Dr. Baraki, I think some folks
in the audience likely know what RA is,
rheumatoid arthritis, but other people
are like, "I've heard of it, unclear."
Can you walk people through what RA is
and and maybe contrast that to
osteoarthritis which people are probably
more familiar with? Yeah, osteoarthritis
is the more common, more familiar form
of arthritis that a lot of people have
heard about. We've done several episodes
um on osteoarthritis including our very
first ever podcast episode, I believe it
was on that topic. I would uh direct
people if they wanted to learn about it
to our more recent, I think it was like
called a teaching rounds episode on
osteoarthritis. That would have been the
better and more updated um you know,
version of that conversation for details
on that. Because I don't want to
simplify and say, "Oh, it's the type
that people know of more and they call
it wear and tear." Because I don't like
that phrase, we don't use that phrase
when talking with people. But that's
what osteoarthritis refers to. Now,
there are a variety of other forms of
arthritis and rheumatoid or RA as uh it
is often abbreviated refers to a form of
inflammatory arthritis. And the reason
it's called that is because the immune
system is involved. The immune system
fundamentally is broken down into two
different kind of arms. There's the um
innate uh immune system and the adaptive
immune system. Uh you might be familiar
with the adaptive immune system as the
one that produces antibodies, for
example, when um we are exposed to
certain foreign uh
you know,
pathogens and things like that.
And so when somebody has a scenario
where that arm, that adaptive wing of
the immune system is kind of misdirected
against our own body, that is known as
an autoimmune disease where the it is
often an anti-antibody mediated attack
on our own tissues. And different immune
autoimmune diseases have a predilection
to attack different organ systems. Um
this is also in contrast to the innate
immune system
uh which can also in certain situations
get turned on and attack our own bodies
in various ways and that is called an
autoinflammatory disease. That's a super
um interesting and less common uh type
of condition. So we have um autoimmune
and autoinflammatory. RA here is a type
of autoimmune disease um where the
body's uh that wing, that adaptive wing
is attacking our body's joints leading
to progressive joint destruction,
deformity, disability, pain, things like
that. And aside from that, RA can also
attack and involve many other tissues of
the body. It can involve the lungs, um
it can involve uh uh the spleen, it can
um involve lots of different tissues uh
in in varying forms and varying
permutations leading to a lot of
different complications. And perhaps
most importantly,
that the chronic inflammatory nature of
it is something that means these
patients with RA are at very high risk
of cardiovascular disease. It's almost
like everything that we talk about here
one way or another ends up coming back
to cardiovascular disease. Here it's the
chronic inflammatory nature where CVD
ends up being the most common cause of
death in patients with rheumatoid
arthritis um barring, you know, them
them having a very severe manifestation
affecting their lungs or something like
that. So that's kind of the the the
summary of it and um so these patients
uh they'll have a little bit of a
different experience compared with those
with osteoarthritis. So whereas in the
early phases before they've gone through
maybe some dedicated rehab as it's kind
of manifesting, people with
osteoarthritis might notice classically,
at least as the textbooks teach us, um a
bit more symptoms, aches and pains with
with more use, quote unquote. So like
worse like later in the day at the end
of a long day of like maybe manual labor
or physical activity, a little bit
achier in that situation. Whereas
patients who have more inflammatory
forms of arthritis,
they might have symptoms that's actually
worse in the morning after they get up
after a period of, you know, relative
rest overnight. And as they get moving,
as they you know, get get get going for
the day, activity tends to actually
improve some of those symptoms. And
that's one of the kind of characteristic
things that we'll tend to ask about is
do you have morning stiffness and how
long does it last? Um and and so if it's
something that tends to improve with a
bit of activity, that would raise our
suspicion for one of these forms of
arthritis. And there there's similar
phenomena that happen in other
inflammatory musculoskeletal conditions.
So people with inflammatory back pain
from ankylosing spondylitis and things
like that. Similar kind of like back
stiffness, worse in the morning, gets
better with activity as the day goes on,
kind of contrasted with more like
traditional common back pain,
non-specific back pain that might be um
you know, worse after a a boatload of of
use as we often will help people through
their their rehab and in their strength
training world and things like that.
Yeah. And and I think when you, you
know, explain it that way, it it would
intuit if it were explained that way
that, "Oh, you should exercise more then
in RA cuz it'll make you feel better."
However, there's still this old adage,
this old, you know, conventional advice,
"You got to protect the joints." Look,
if RA is damaging the joints, then you
shouldn't exercise cuz that's just more
damage. But the evidence doesn't support
that at all. There are many, many
studies on exercise in RA uh across wide
range of different modalities.
Everything from barbell training, free
weight training, machine-based training,
band-based training, aquatic, I mean
just you name it, it's been studied. And
almost universally,
an improvement in not only quality of
life, function, uh health markers, but
but also reductions in pain. Like people
just do reasonably well uh almost across
the board here. Um and no radiographic
uh evidence of joint damage, although
again that's really insufficient to kind
of explain people's symptoms as we know.
But the most interesting thing, at least
to me, is that there does appear to be
some disease-modifying activity here. Um
we think this is mostly related to the
anti-inflammatory effect, the net
anti-inflammatory effect of exercise.
Now, when you think about exercise,
yeah, there's some muscle breakdown,
there's some stress on on the tissues
and so that is inflammatory to some
degree. However, the net effect of
exercise is anti-inflammatory, mostly
mediated through myokines. These are
little proteins that are released from
uh active muscle tissue that act as
hormones. And so that kind of contrasts
the inflammatory nature of rheumatoid
arthritis. So it can actually modify the
disease itself. Effectively the same
targets that the medications these
people may be on. So we're talking about
CRP, IL-6, TNF alpha. Uh so some some
overlap there. And that's I think one of
the reasons why the evidence uh is so
good on RA and and exercise. And in
fact, this is reflected in the latest
guidelines. The European Alliance of
Associations for Rheumatology, the UK
NICE, and the American College of
Rheumatology guidelines all are
currently recommending exercise, both
aerobic and resistance training. They've
all moved to this sort of new paradigm.
So despite that being the case, in
practice many patients may still be
getting the same old advice to not
exercise, don't stress the joints,
mainly because guideline adoption can
lag. It's not a problem with the
guidelines per se, it's just that people
may not be up to date. So some practical
considerations. You can give me a yes or
no on this, Dr. Baraki. Let me see what
you think about this.
So if a person has like an active flare,
um so they might notice like hot,
swollen joints, elevated uh symptoms
otherwise, this would be an indication
to reduce not only the absolute load, so
the weights that they're lifting, but
also probably the amount of training.
Wouldn't recommend stopping per se, but
whatever the person can tolerate. Kind
of sounds like our general approach to
injuries. How does that strike you?
Yeah. Yeah, I I you know, this active RA
flares is not a situation where the
correct path of treatment is
immobilization. They can move, right?
It's not the time to push into your
training necessarily while you talk with
your doctor and get it under control and
then you can return to more regular
training. So immobilization not needed,
normal activities and movement is fine.
Yes. Yeah. Uh and because RA often
affects the wrists, the fingers, and
this is how we interact with our
environment including in the gym, it may
be preferable to use machines, uh for
example, or other things that are less
grip dependent, especially during flares
or especially early on um in an
individual's fitness journey, uh
especially if they haven't really been
exposed to exercise before. Straps can
also be useful here. It's more of a
practical consideration. How does that
strike you? Yeah, I think it's totally
fine. I've had several patients over the
years um with RA-related grip issues and
it's just like, "Okay, use straps. It's
okay." Yeah. Use the tools. Uh another
practical sort of tip here would be like
an extended warm-up. Now, you know, we
get a lot of questions, "Should I
stretch? Should I do this active
mobilization? Should I get a band out
and root around a foam roller or
whatever?" And generally we're like,
"Look, if it makes you feel better and
you like it and you got time to spare,
go go for it." But in this particular
case, I it's not that I would recommend
those types of movements for a uh a
warm-up. But I would just consider
extending or protracting the warm-up. So
if the person's going to start with a
leg press, for example, maybe not just
starting on the leg press, but other
sort of dynamic exercises. Mainly it
sort of refers to this idea that they're
more stiff earlier on and to the extent
you can get somebody to kind of uh
desensitize themselves through more
move-created exposure to to different
movements, that would be a a good idea.
Thoughts? Very reasonable. No comments.
Yeah, and the last part here, this is
more for the coaches rather than health
care professionals. Um there's a
difference, at least in my experience,
between folks who would who have what
what what I would consider
well-controlled RA versus uncontrolled
RA. So whether that's their medication
regimen, other aspects of their medical
treatment. Individuals with
well-controlled RA tend to have, at
least again in my experience, less
flares. They seem to tolerate more
exercise generally um better. So if I
were to work with somebody with who
says, "Look, I've been having flares all
the time. We haven't really sussed out
the correct medication regimen for me,
but they decidedly kind of an
uncontrolled RA person. It's not that I
would say look exercise isn't for you
right now. It's just I would be more
cautious with with that person. How does
that strike you? Yeah, also reasonable.
Yeah, right. Well, to me the coach in
this question is doing the right thing.
This is what evidence-based coaching
actually looks like in practice. The
client's getting stronger, the symptoms
are better, and the research supports
exactly what they're doing. Keep going.
Nice job. Gold star. Yeah, agree. I know
this question asked or I believe I think
somebody who I've worked with we know uh
coached for a long time, so not
surprising. He's he's doing a great job.
There you go.